so I've got the QR code to um a little
quiz that I built two days ago actually
up there you can scan that and do it or
it's also we're gonna come back to it
later so do it in your in your own time
but yeah I was like yesterday I was
worrying about should I do it with like
is it going to take too long so I
thought okay I'll just have the QR code
up there
um so I don't know if anyone had the
chance to scan it if you wanted to scan
it else it will pop up again later today
as well
um so uh thank you so much for having me
here I'm really excited to present today
my name is elinka Barson I'm a director
of data science at Wonderman Thompson
which is a creative agency
um and I've got quite a kind of I'm I
feel very privileged to be in the role
that I am so I'm one of the founding
members of our Global creative data
Group which is a little um
interdisciplinary group of we've got so
we've got the data science department
and sa Department it's me and then it's
one other data scientist and then we've
got developers
um one developer then we've got creative
technologists so we've got design and
copywriting covered and we work together
to build creative data um I guess
prototypes and products so a lot of
prototyping and then
um the occasional kind of product once
we get once we get to the stage of
actually building it
um and it's a very it's a kind of
privileged position because we work like
the data science we work at intersection
of those different disciplines so I kind
of have to collaborate with creatives
kind of traditional creatives on a
day-to-day basis and kind of learn how
they kind of things like user experience
and user flow is so important but might
not be that important to you if you're
just working on the backend coding so
it's kind of been a really interesting
experience
so that's my team and then I also wanted
to tell you a little bit about myself so
you can see a little picture of me on my
first birthday I'm Romanian I was born
in Romania and in Romania it's it's a
tradition that you at your first
birthday you kind of get presented with
a plate and your parents will have
placed like different objects on that
plate and in theory like whatever you
pick from that plate is supposed to kind
of Be Your Destiny your professional
Destiny so I actually ended up picking a
coloring pencil and a calculator which
didn't make much sense at all I think my
parents were just hoping for the
calculator rather than the coloring
pencil
um but it kind of it's been kind of
interesting looking back back at this
and thinking oh maybe there is like a
little bit of Truth to that
um so I always wanted to be a writer I
think part of me still wants to be a
writer
um I was always kind of growing up I was
kind of the creative kid I was always
scribbling um I was painting I was
drawing
um kind of not very drawn to kind of
math and all of those kind of things
um there was more something that I felt
like I maybe just wasn't very good at so
I enjoyed the creative side more I then
studied sociology and politics because I
thought okay I want to be a creative but
maybe aiming to be a novelist or a
writer in that sense isn't a very
realistic choice so I thought okay maybe
I can be a journalist and kind of get
that subject knowledge background so and
then after that I kind of realized okay
I'm really interested in the internet
kind of obsessed with the internet and I
realized okay this is actually something
I could also study
um in kind of from a sociology from a
sociological point of view so I did my
undergrad thesis was actually about how
older adults in sheltered housing were
using the internet and kind of learning
to use computers for the first time and
I realized oh that's like fascinating
and you can actually make this your
academic career or kind of your next
step so then I did a master's in Social
data science so um a master's in social
science of the internet and I realized
oh I could kind of go so I had done
interviews previously and I thought okay
I could kind of go down the career path
of keep doing qualitative research or I
could just get a little bit out of my
comfort zone and kind of try to learn
all the programming that they were
offering and so that's kind of the route
I went down and I kind of fell in love
with programming because I realized once
you add programming in a programming
language to your creative toolkit
there's just so many amazing things you
could do and it gave me like the same
satisfaction that I had previously
gotten from just kind of like writing
something and then editing it and then
being happy with it
um so then I started working for wpp
which is the parent company of the
agency that I work at now and I was able
to kind of experiment with a few
different roles and it slowly shifted
from strategy into data science and
that's how I ended up in the role that I
am now but this is something that I've
kind of been grappling with for the past
five years or so like did I abandon my
creative Pursuits because if you say I'm
a data scientist people kind of think
okay you're like a left brain thinking
kind of person and then I I kind of felt
like maybe I was like betraying my
younger self or something at times I
feel like it's been like an up and down
so
um the talk that I'm gonna give today is
really I feel like as much a little
therapy session for myself as it is like
hopefully going to be useful for you
guys to kind of think about and frame it
a little bit
um yeah so I want to make the argument
that data science is inherently creative
and I think that's it's kind of there's
a lot of interesting
um discussions going on right now with
tools like dally to like creating
incredibly realistic images
um GPT 3D can do like some beautiful
poetry so there's all this talk about
our machines about to replace creatives
and I think that is kind of an
interesting I've got like my own point
of view that I love to talk about as
well but it's kind of that's not the
point of my talk here I want to make an
argument for the fact that as data
scientists we are engaging in like
inherently creative work like no matter
where you are in the data science
workflow okay
um so this is that that was my intro the
second part I'm gonna move on to the
test yourself if you've got I'm gonna
have the QR code up again in a second if
anyone didn't get a chance to do it so
kind of finding out what's your creative
data type and to build that I mean it's
not a very scientific framework I'm
gonna be honest but I kind of took like
those traditional classifications of
data scientists and I loved like if you
were at the New York Times uh talk you
kind of saw the Venn diagram with like
subject knowledge um coding expertise
and then I think the statistics and I
was kind of thinking about that and
thinking about how this might apply to
different types of people in kind of
thinking about creative data science
um and then uh I'm moving on to the
actual topic of the talk which is data
science as a creative discipline and
I've split it in two parts so I'm going
to talk about the approach and the
process as creative first and then about
the output and how we communicate that
output as also kind of a creative
discipline and then some questions at
the end okay so this is if you didn't
get a chance to do this before
um you can also if you're on your laptop
you can just type it in it's
um ilinka Valentina dot python
anymore.com this is also really going to
test
my deployment skills for like that flask
up because I have no idea
um how many people can do it at the same
time
if everyone has it
um I'm also going to go so I wanted to
it should bring you to a little website
I was also two days ago I was kind of
Googling how to make like an HTML
template look really nice which I feel
like has given me new respect for like
our design team and development team
okay so I just wanted to very quickly um
talk you through my answers to the quiz
so the first one is what complement
would you be most excited to receive and
I've chosen that I'd be most excited to
receive a compliment that you're so
resourceful I can't believe you taught
yourself all of this over the weekend
that would take other people months I
feel like that would make me really
happy and then which task would you
rather fast forward
um I would probably rather fast forward
like the endless optimization process
um because I'm a perfectionist at some
things but then really not in others so
I kind of get a little impatient and if
it's working we should just move on in
my opinion but
um that could be a little controversial
so um what's the first thing you do on a
new data project I kind of like to
sketch out like what kind of my hopes
for the project and where I could um
where I could really go and then I kind
of figure out like who to get involved
to actually make it happen and then what
makes a data set particularly juicy to
you I think it's anything with like an
emotive hook and if you could weave
together different data sets in an
unexpected way to tell a story that gets
me very excited and then I'm not going
to read these pickup lines to you
because I'm slightly embarrassed but you
can read them in your own time and then
my response was um the tinkerer as I had
two responses for the tinkerer and then
the Storyteller one response and then
the Visionary which is kind of a
pretentious name but whatever
um word response so um talking about so
these are the five types that you might
have gotten and obviously these are not
one doesn't exclude the other I think a
lot of data scientists will have like
qualities from each of those probably
um just to go through them really
quickly the Storyteller is really
excited about communicating and
Distilling complex topics into very
simple language and like very beautiful
visuals and the Storyteller is usually
quite popular because they're the one to
volunteer to do like any kind of talks
and presentations so if they have people
on their team would rather not do that
um that's I feel like they're quite
popular for that then the Tinker which
was like my number one response and the
Tinker likes to experiment with code and
also with ideas and kind of diving right
into the programming process knowing
that the first iteration is probably not
going to work and they're gonna have to
restart the whole thing again they get
prototypes up and running fairly quickly
and if you're anything like myself you
might also have like a Raspberry Pi
collecting dust at home where you had
all these great project ideas but never
actually followed through so that can be
a struggle and then the Artisan I think
is great because they do things really
efficiently and beautifully it's really
about focused depth and quality and
they're really good at kind of the deep
and focused work and that can be a
anything it could be like building a
data engineering pipeline perfectly or
like really doing like interactive
visualization for the web really
beautifully but it's all about kind of
the depths of work
then the inventor is kind of the um I
guess the scientist
um of all of the types so they like to
really dig into the science and the math
um they like to kind of come up with
novel solutions to very complex problems
um they're a secret academic and if they
don't have a login to academic journals
then they probably ask like anyone they
know if they have a login or can send
them a PDF of this in that paper so I
think they're obviously amazing and then
the Visionary is all about the bigger
picture and the business impact they use
their intuition and their ability to
inspire to really kind of bring people
together and often they'll be in kind of
like team leadership roles I would say
like the guy who leads our team is
definitely a little bit of a visionary
um and then I wanted to actually use
this framework to kind of move
um to kind of move through the
presentation and not just kind of give
you this quiz
um so you'll see like the exclamation
marks and you also see the hearts um
throughout the presentation and this is
kind of opportunities and also where
different types might do things really
well already so in in this example for
example
um this area might be an opportunity for
um the artisan and the inventor to kind
of like maybe expand or go a little bit
out of their comfort zone and then in
this case
um the Visionary the tinkerer and the
Storyteller might already like be pretty
comfortable with that topic
okay so then moving on to approach and
process
um the first thing I wanted to talk
about is this concept of remix and
borrow
um there's all these ideas like steal
like an artist and no idea is actually
original because everything has been
done before
um and I think as data scientists were
actually in a great position with this
because we do a lot of remixing just by
the nature of our job we very rarely
will like write an entire project from
scratch and I feel like we're very
comfortable like finding Solutions
um taking like code Snippets and
solutions and then obviously like always
giving credit but it's it's kind of a
process that we are really um
really familiar with the remixing
um and the borrowing aspect but I think
this can also be kind of taking from
different disciplines so in advertising
like if you think about advertising
analytics it kind of is almost like a
menu of things you can do like you can
do some a b testing you could do some
segmentation but actually like going
into other disciplines and figuring out
like where does my background come in
where can I borrow from other
disciplines so I'm a big fan of network
science from that kind of the social
network analytics and I've really
enjoyed like taking that into a field
where it's maybe not so often used and
kind of applying it in unexpected ways
um I think that Tinker the Visionary and
the Storyteller are probably really good
at this already maybe an opportunity for
growth for the artisan and the inventor
but I don't really think so in the data
science context because I think we
probably do this all the time but it's
kind of nice to just
um yeah just make yourself aware of some
of the practices that you might not
really think of as creative but are
actually very unusual in other
disciplines
um done collaboration um collaboration
is really interesting and you might be
lucky and be kind of in an organization
and a team where you are forced to do
that every day anyways I'm kind of
forced to do that if my code or if my
model takes two minutes to execute our
like designer and ux designer is going
to come to me and say we need to like
figure out a way to turn this into 30
seconds so that collaboration can be um
kind of help I guess take the work to
the next level but there's also many
organizations where data science is
going to be very insular and you might
collaborate with technology or those
kind of teams but you don't necessarily
um
collaborate with more unexpected
colleagues like creatives so I think
that's a it's it's kind of a very
valuable thing to do to get their
perspective
um and there's an interesting bit of
research on kind of the out the the
effect of collaboration on Creative
performance the original
um paper was actually built on Broadway
musicals and they were kind of looking
at the small network of people involved
in making Broadway musicals and they
found that if they looked at artistic
performance and creative performance so
kind of financial performance and
reviews and then also how many people
were involved in making something
um there's up to a certain threshold
more collaboration is gonna like push
your kind of product and your creative
output to the next level but once you
cross a certain threshold it's kind of
like the too many cooks concept it like
actually diminishes it I think that's
just kind of a fascinating piece of
research from kind of an unexpected
discipline
um but yeah I'm sure I feel like that's
very relatable just thinking about the
amount of as soon as you've got too many
people involved sometimes it's like
really hard to actually get work done
and it's kind of been a conversation in
my team as we think about how can we
expand because right now we're only six
people how can we expand without kind of
losing the um I guess the positive
aspect of collaboration
um I think the Visionary and the
Storyteller are probably pretty good at
this already I think maybe it's an
opportunity for depending on how where
you're working for the inventor the
tinker and The Artisan
um to kind of think about how you can
collaborate with maybe unexpected
colleagues
um then this idea of constraints and
that constraints are actually very
creative so um this idea of kind of
paralysis of choice and there's been
research done on when people are
presented with kind of um they can do
anything or they have like a certain set
of constraints they actually come up
with um more varied and more ideas if
they have that set of constraints
um and I think that's kind of
interesting to think about so in my team
I'm always kind of constrained just by
the fact that we have to build a
user-friendly creative output at the end
of something so whatever I'm doing kind
of has to work in that limit and
sometimes that means I can't use like
almost computationally intensive models
and I just have to find kind of simpler
ways to do it this but kind of seeing
the creativity in that
um and there was actually one
interesting project we worked on earlier
this year about where I was really aware
of this so we had to build um an model
of epidemiology
an epidemic model to my model spread of
a disease not covet thank goodness but
it became because it was for a Pharma
client it became very obvious that we'd
have to base this on peer-reviewed
research and because of a few different
constraints we actually ended up
realizing okay the only paper we can use
is this paper from 20 years ago that was
written in Microsoft Excel definitely no
code base available or anything like
that so it was kind of interesting
um realizing that working within those
constraints and this kind of breaking
down the problem and like ordering a
book on Markov chains from 1997 is
actually kind of like creative and fun
and I feel like it was um very
satisfying at the end to realize oh we
were able to reproduce those results
just kind of pulling in from all
different areas
um yeah as data scientists I feel like
time the tools we can use and money were
like faced with those constraints always
um I think the um the inventor the the
artisan and the Storyteller are probably
already pretty good at those constraints
I think the tinkerer can be like
overwhelmed by all the things they could
they might be able to teach themselves
and I think the Visionary also have to
be like reeled in sometimes a little bit
because they get to get excited about
all the different possibilities
um so Focus I think is actually really
good for creativity and I mean everyone
will have those constraints but if you
have them if you don't have them just
artificially um creating them I think is
super valuable okay so this first part
was all about the tools we're using so
and how I think that like the actual
process and the approach we take to data
science has the possibility to be very
creative and I didn't really talk about
data collection here but I think the way
we collect our data because it's often
it's I mean most of the time it's not as
as easy as just downloading a CSV that
we can use that's like that's a very
that can be a very creative like
creative process too
okay so next thing I'm going to move on
to how the output and how we communicate
that output is actually um has like
great creative potential as well so I'm
going to talk about output first
um so the output so I I mentioned like
daily and um gpt3 in the beginning I
mean there are so many models like that
now and I think it's important to kind
of just mention those as something where
the approach might be creative but also
the output is like in and of itself a
creative output so this was just a
little project I did a few years ago
where I took
um a book of not a book a data set of
poetry written by kids and a trained a
neural network on it to generate kind of
new poetries based new new poems based
on that data and this was one of the
results I got I'm a giraffe that bounces
in a tree I score very basketball I
bounce on the field and I thought that
was kind of a very um sweet little poem
written by an AI and sometimes it was
difficult like looking at the AI
generated
poems even though it wasn't a huge data
set and the ones like written by kids
they had a lot of um obviously because
it was trained on that data but it was
interesting it was hard something times
to tell those apart and then I'm also
almost like embarrassed to show you the
following few slides because I feel like
image generation has changed so much
just in the past year or so this was
something we built in 2021 which was
actually for one of our offices they
wanted an art like an AI driven art
installation so we built um they kind of
have like a big screen and we built this
generator where people can type in show
me a show me bunnies fighting in space
and then it projects on the wall in the
lobby which is super fun and so this was
Bunny's fighting in space this is AI on
the tennis court
and then the graffiti of Garfield
um but it's just amazing thinking if I
use dally too now to give me a graffiti
of Garfield it would not look like this
like here you can really tell that AI
still did it which I kind of like that
stage I'm not sure
um the current stage how I feel about it
yet but yeah we'll see
um and then I wanted to give you an
example of an actual product that we
built as well because those were kind of
more like fun like side projects almost
like internal tools we were building
um this was something that we built for
Sherwin Williams it's called speaking in
color and the idea was that color is
such a personal thing to everyone and if
I talk about Fall Foliage in Vermont I'm
probably thinking of a very different
color that you might be thinking of and
the challenge was kind of how can we
take language and then transform it into
a color that Architects and also just
general users might be able to go into a
store and purchase
um so because yeah everyone is going to
think of a very different
um a very different type of like Fall
Foliage and the swatches kind of
resulting from that are going to be very
different too so these are three
examples of like perfectly accurate fall
for the Irish colors depending on what
what time you're thinking of so the tool
was kind of using
um was using kind of voice protection
and then natural language processing to
translate
into color kind of that first search and
then what was interesting was we would
also allow people to adjust it
afterwards so you could say something
like make it more sad make it more 1970s
and then you could kind of tweak it
until you're happy with the result so
that was a super satisfying and fun
project to work on
and then the power of prototyping this
is one of my quotes that I go back to
over and over again and it's so the
quote is if it breaks that means it's
real and the background for this is we
were gonna go to a client meeting and we
had built this prototype that was really
like stapled together because it was
quite a hard thing to build and it was
probably not ready yet to be shared with
the client so before the presentation we
warned him that it might break and it
did break which was very stressful but
he actually said I like I like the
possibility of it breaking because if it
can break that means it's real and you
didn't kind of fake the Prototype so I
think there's a lot of value in actually
showing people like a little Glimpse
behind the curtain of what we built
um and I don't think these needs to look
this needs to be like a perfect project
I think just a collab notebook you can
share with someone and you can like
annotate a little bit and then walk
someone through like part of your
modeling or part of your data pipeline I
found that even people who don't have a
data background actually really
really appreciate the Glimpse behind the
curtain and it also forces you to to
kind of
um communicate your project in in that
kind of way and kind of figuring out
like which part of this can actually
make interactive and share rather than
just having slides
um yeah I think the tinkerer and the
Visionary are pretty good at that
already and maybe an opportunity for
growth um if you're more of an artisan
an inventor or a storyteller
okay and then um another point about
talking to the non-nerds
um because we love them and we really
need them because often creativity
happens where we can package our
insights in a way that they can use it
and kind of build on that
um and I think that's always a really
interesting challenge if you need to and
I mean that's also kind of related to
the prototyping but if you need to
package a concept in a way that someone
who has no idea about data science can
understand I think there's a lot of
potential for creativity
um
Storyteller and Visionary I think I'm
pretty good at that and maybe the ones
who are more like heads down coding are
sometimes struggling with that
um but I wanted to show you this example
that I used so we were actually doing we
do a lot of work with computer vision
and we want people to understand like
what are the opportunities with computer
vision but maybe also what are like the
potential pitfalls
um so I used the popular food or animal
Meme and I used the Google Vision AI to
um Google Vision API to run the
following images through it so this
first one is Chihuahua or blueberry
muffin and I was curious because I
struggle with these sometimes like is AI
going to be good at recognizing that
um and we actually I think pretty good I
think there's on let's see okay yeah
there's one muffin in like the lower row
that's been defined as an animal but
generally pretty good I mean the the one
like
bottom left corner just looks like a
muffin to me
um then golden doodle or fried chicken I
think these might be like the most
difficult ones potentially
um and AI definitely had some trouble
with that often misclassifying the
golden doodle no the other way around
the Fried Chicken as a golden doodle
um and then the last one sloth or
chocolate croissant
and actually surprisingly good though I
think bottom right you can see that
there's a chocolate croissant
um classified as an animal so that was
kind of a fun way to walk through the an
example that we wouldn't use to build
anything but just kind of show like
things like the importance of the data
that said that something is training on
like being able to spot those mistakes
and just also the opportunities because
I mean it's some of these are hard so
it's pretty cool that we're at a point
where without this was just the out of
the box Google Vision API we hadn't
trained it on those I'm sure if you
actually like trained on top of that you
could get some really good resembles uh
some really good results okay and then
the final bit is when it comes to
communication I think like getting a
little bit personal or like showing
people a little bit of like yourself and
your personality and a talk is a really
good and valuable thing to do because
sometimes we have these impressive
models
um and especially if I mean I feel like
data scientists are going to be very
excited about them but especially if
your audience is broader than that just
kind of
um yeah making it a little bit personal
so I love to watercolors so I watercolor
all my slides and I'm excited that now
people can see my slides at least like
within the company and say oh that's
those are Linker slides so whatever that
thing is for you I think that's like a
really a good exercise just to kind of
become like aware of that and then
um use it yeah
so I think to just to sum up I think now
I'm pretty confident saying that no I
did not kind of um abandon my childhood
creative Pursuits I think data science
is a field with like a lot of potential
for creativity
um and I'm very excited to be a data
scientist
um yeah so at the end just um yeah we've
got all of these again and if you have
any questions and I also love if you
manage to do the quiz just to like get a
show of hands for the different types
how many people got the inventor
okay we've got one there then the
Visionary
the Storyteller oh a lot of storytellers
that's awesome
um the tinkerer
you too and then the artisan
awesome that's so interesting I feel
like we've got a we've got a great mix
here but yeah that's everything for me
and please like yeah if you have any
other questions
um get in touch and also we have time
for questions now I think because I did
okay on time
foreign
oh yeah
um so the um so it worked I have like I
think I'm sure I have a sketch of it
some somewhere
um but it started with you got you got
on the side you speak like
show me the color show me the color
purple or something like you would
probably wouldn't say that but you would
say show me the color of Fall Foliage in
Vermont and then the first step that was
actually purely front end where we
actually
um our developer was pulling in a search
API that was then kind of analyzing the
proportion of color in that image and
then you get you get served kind of um a
palette of potential images and then you
make like as a user you make your first
choice and then that's kind of feeds
into where the back end came in so after
that first choice you have the ability
to adjust and there are some adjustments
that are super easy like um make it
brighter make it darker that's an
obvious adjustment but some adjustments
that are maybe a little more subtle like
make it sad or
um and we also had a few Easter eggs
like there like if you wanted to make it
more Prince it would know that Prince
and purple are kind of like often
thought of together so we would make it
more purple
um but the actual adjustment would work
we didn't we used both RGB models and
the hsl model of color and we did some
language processing to kind of
understand similarity of words and how
like if if we're saying sad is that
actually which word that we know is that
the closest to and then we kind of made
those adjustments and then you got to
the final color
so yeah it was a it was fun
oh sorry
that was our team as well but it was um
the developer who and we kind of have a
split work we kind of at the beginning
we figure out what is really easy for
the project to pull in where we don't
need to open apis and then like if if
there's something that we kind of need
our customers
build our apis in flask and then post on
Google app engine or like sometimes you
use like other products like Coral weave
I don't know if anyone has used that if
it's like more computationally intensive
questions
foreign
oh yeah of course uh one second
you're a director how do you try to
engage
so actually
um I'm hoping that at some point we'll
get to the point where we'll have
external hiring right now we're in a
point where we were able to kind of
transition people out of more
traditional advertising analytics roles
from the agency if they've kind of shown
interest or if they kind of yeah if
they're if they're interested in getting
involved with us so that's how we've
done our hiring of like our one
data scientist who's awesome so far so
it's going to be really interesting
because if you have data scientists on
paper you kind of I mean I do think that
every data site is is creative but you
also have to enjoy this very particular
process that we do so yeah it's kind of
a challenge for the future that I'm kind
of yeah excited
for
I don't really have a question but just
wanted to say okay
a fellow Romanian
foreign
that's a great question so I that's kind
of fun where we sit in the team because
in advertising often you will have teams
attached to different clients and then
they only work on that client but we
kind of get pulled into projects and we
also do a lot of pictures so we
um Sherwin Williams as kind of like a
color or paint manufacturer then we've
definitely done some work with Pharma
though you are very if you're a tinkerer
that can be a struggle because you're
very kind of restricted in what you can
do there for like excellent reasons
um and then also clients just like um
any um like beverage clients or um let
me think what we're working on right now
like food it can really be like across
the Spectrum which is very fun
no I wish
I feel like um sometimes we we kind of
try to internal things that we work on
um I think I want to kind of start a
practice where we kind of write those up
and then see if we can actually publish
things but that's kind of second too of
the actual the day-to-day work but yeah
no journalism
foreign
thank you so much and thanks for
participating
[Applause]